we've come to the Kalahari Desert in
Africa to witness one of MA nature's
classic confrontations in this corner of
the desert feeding on succulent bulbs
insects and small vertebrates that
sociable critter the meerkat in this
corner of the desert feeding on rodents
birds other snakes and of course
meerkats
with a nasty deadly venomous bite that
can easily kill humans the puff adder
you think the meerkats would vamoose out
of there with a threat like this and bad
news they bunched tightly together they
actually advanced on the puff adder puff
adder versus meerkat meerkat versus puff
adder eyeball-to-eyeball who's gonna
blink first the meerkats smartly wave
their tails high in the air to focus the
snakes attention there and to keep it
from striking at their heads the fuzzy
adorable meerkats actually have the puff
adder retreating the meerkat puffs look
on as the adults take care of business I
think we've got a winner
it's the meerkats in a unanimous
decision as the puff adder skedaddle and
the meerkats marinate in the glory of
victory